Всім привіт! Мене звати Анна Домніч
І саме зараз час трохи розім'ятись після навчання
Я думаю, кожен із вас знає, що спорт — це
сила, краса та здоров'я
І це дуже корисно для нашого організму
Тож, пропоную вам доєднатись
до наших драйвових руханок
і зарядитись позитивом.
Розпочинаємо!
Всім привіт, дорогі друзі!
Я сподіваюсь, що ви вже скучили
за нашими спортивними руханками
і ви готові драйвово потанцювати разом з нами
В мене сьогодні в гостях Олександр Усік
і Наталя Годунко
Нічого собі! Наталя вже готова
до нашої спортивної руханки
Я пропоную почати з того, що ми
зробимо гарну розминку з вами
Як ми будемо робити розминку?
Ми будемо починати з голови,
потім плечі
Допомагайте мені. Що далі у нас?
Після плечей що будемо розминати?
Як що? Ручки, спину
Так, спину, потім колінки наші,
ніжки і стопи
Я сподіваюсь, що всі готові
Тож, давайте розпочинати!
Почнемо з того, що ми будемо правильно дихати
Ми вдихаємо носиком,
Видихаємо ротиком
І три рази ще
Глибокий вдих
Видих.
Ще раз
Ну що, ми готові?
Давайте із музикою спробуємо одразу розминку
[лунає музика]
Вперед 8 разів
І в сторони.
Раз, прямо, раз, прямо
Раз, прямо
І по колу
Сильно-сильно потягнутись до плечиків вушками
І в ліву сторону
Поклали ручку і розтягуємо
І раз, іншу
І ще
Кисті
Рівно
Так, можна потанцювати
І по колу
І поїхали
В іншу сторону
І летимо вперед
В улюблену країну свою летимо
Не пливемо поки що
І повертаємось назад
Сильно-сильно
А тепер пливемо
Отак навіть крутіше!
Можна ще присідати
І тягнемось всі до Олександра
Рівненько
В іншу сторону до Наталі
І ще раз
Рівненько
Вперед
І до ніжок хто може дотягнутись
А тепер за п'яточки туди.
Назад
І вдихнути наверх.
Раз
Два
І ще раз
Раз
Два, вниз
Три
Чотири
І за п'яточки.
П'ять, шість
Вдихаємо.
Ще два рази
Раз, два
Три, чотири
П'ять, шість
І наверх
Останній раз
І наверх видихаємо
По колу.
Малюємо коло
І в іншу сторону
Супер. Які ви молодці!
Готові далі?
У нас ще колінки залишились, ніжки і стопи. Так?
Звичайно
Готові?
Так
Давайте. Розминаємо наші колінки
Раз, раз, раз
В іншу сторону
Раз
І по черзі
Обережно
Давайте додамо.
Як ви там робили?
Раз, раз
У кожного свої рухи
Можна в сторони так
І на раз підняти ніжку.
Раз
В сторону, два.
Поставити назад, три
І забрати назад, чотири
Ще раз
Раз, два, поставити
Три, чотири
А тепер ще треба натягнути носочок
Ось так.
Раз, два
О, прекрасно!
Три і забрати, чотири
І ще давайте
Раз, два
Три і чотири
А тепер трохи швидше
Раз і забрати
І ще
Раз.
Давайте з ручкою. Прекрасна ідея!
І лівою давайте
Раз, два.
Забрати
Раз, забрати
І ще
З ручками.
Професійно
Раз
Давайте пострибаємо на місці
І навхрест
Раз
Навхрест
В сторони
Раз
І на місці крокуємо
Головне — посміхатися і отримувати задоволення
Вперед поїхали
Ще
Ще трохи
Давайте-давайте
Дихаємо
Вниз
Повисіти трохи знизу
І, вдихаючи носиком, раз
І ще раз
Не забувайте дихати
І плескаємо собі
Останній раз
Вдихаємо
[лунає дзвінок]
Давайте п'ять. Ви молодці!
Тільки розім'ялися!
І, мені здається, продзвенів дзвоник
Тож...
Ні, ще не бігти!